what do you think of his chip he really
he put out a chip that he said is
uh the most powerful one oh yeah i mean
it's
it's a good chip it's i'm not sure
whether or not it's sufficient for uh
true level five self-driving uh i think
the
consensus um is is
honestly just pretty varied what i will
say is
for the workloads right now that most of
these self-driving cars are
companies are running it's not enough
it's not enough yeah what's interesting
to me is
on a highway it's flawless yeah
on the streets i when i have
self-driving also on my honda odyssey
to keep like laying keep you in lane
like the rudimentary
like i think it's a major jump between
when i get off the sixth street exit
here and i'm in san francisco
and you drive through the tenderloin or
market street
that's a whole different problem to
solve
than the 280. yeah i mean this is this
is exactly why
this type of chip isn't enough because
on the highway it's it's actually pretty
ironically it's pretty constrained
there's only a certain number of things
that can happen on the highway there's
only a certain number of things you can
see
for example you're never going to see a
pedestrian on the highway no you're
never going to see a pedestrian and if
you hit a pedestrian on the highway
nobody's blaming you yeah they're like
why is there a pedestrian on the highway
this person's committing suicide exactly
but in these city environments you have
you know orders of magnitude more inputs
you have very you have more variable
speed even just
planning you know a trajectory to get
from
you know the beginning of the block to
the end of the block might
be very challenging if in the middle of
your trajectory there's a person
that happens to decide okay i'm gonna
jaywalk and walk across the street yeah
uh and for the level of safety that's
required for
sort of government regulations but also
for consumer adoption
uh it i mean again the amount of compute
that you need to do to get there
is not enough and that's including
elon's chip